[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and this has been a long time coming
this this episode has actually been two
years in the making i sat with isin art
and once I knew that the statue would
become available it's a custom statue I
know I needed to have it not I needed to
have it I had to have it I had to be one
of the 50 people that possessed this
statue and it's such a rarity because
there are two distinct colors in this
statute but I'm getting ahead of myself
here I'm getting way ahead of myself
here because let me introduce you to
God Emperor do I think he's trying to
say King what's going on how do we get
to this point you know who is this dude
here's the biggest of the bad he is the
baddest villain ever the grace of Marvel
page he is what a villain a true villain
they're supposed to be
you understand he is solely motivated by
power he believes that his rule is the
only rule how did we get to this one so
you say King I remember him being green
yeah that's regular Victor Von Doom who
first appeared in Fantastic Four number
five and Doom went on to battle the
likes of the x-men the Avengers a
constant in the Fantastic Four he did
team ups with yours truly Namor as a
matter of fact I happen to have one of
the books laying around right now it's
called a super villain team-up with him
and a savage Submariner no I tell you I
read these books $0.25 number for
February I don't know what
here is this that this came out but um
yeah I am a huge fan of Victor Von Doom
because he is exactly the genesis of
every villain you see some villains are
motivated by greed some motivated by
power some are motivated by what of a
driving force love Victor Von Doom was
driven and is driven by every last one
of those properties the love of his
mother see what a lot of people don't
know about Victor Von Doom
that's not even talked about God Emperor
doing this is that's the ultimate Victor
Von Doom is an accomplished sorcerer
where he can battle the likes of dr.
strange he has battled I am in
toe-to-toe he has battled Thor one on
one
so when I tell you that this villain has
always seeked power remember when the
surfer came to earth Victor Von Doom was
the one who grabbed the Muppets and
tried to siphon his power from him
remember doom had the surfboard so what
we have to understand is what we're
dealing with right here is ultimate
power hungry individual with given the
power what would happen well given the
power he turns into God Emperor doom now
this is how it came about and the secret
Wars the second one not the first one
we're touching on the first one one of
these days but the second secret Wars
the secret Wars brought the planets well
the multiverse together it was a
collection of the multiverse and the six
one six world the multiverse that we are
used to that's when we grew up with with
the Incredible Hulk Doc rules bana you
know and then you had the sixteen ten
universe which was the ultimate universe
with Miles Morales and characters of
that nature it was like a mirror how
would you say of the six one six by
his the huge difference in the ultimate
universe the ultimate universe was
really grounded like the MCU soul it's
grounded in today's traditional ways
where the 606 is just a year you know
what we've walked with so what happened
is the world was collapsing and they
collapse and they ended but not for
doing not from Victor Von Doom what he
decided and what he felt was this is an
opportunity so he took the powers from
the Beyonder with the power of the
molecule man because the molecule man is
probably unlimited but he lacks
imagination Victor Von Doom is not short
on imagination so
doom uses the power to form battle world
as an amalgamation of both realities and
he had all the heroes from both
realities on this world where he was a
sole ruler his deputy and chief was a
sorceress supreme dr. strange and he had
a villains and heroes alike all the post
about a world where you know certain
regions was run by mr. sinister and
stuff like that and doing ruled with an
iron fist now I know you saying
get out of here King it's no way he's
stronger than Thanos oh hold on wait a
second Thanos tried his hand at this he
tried challenging God Emperor doom hmm
that was stupid
as you can see in this panel here just
really didn't go well for your boy
Daniels but at the same time you say
king he's not stronger than the Infinity
Gauntlet
well T'Challa
our favorite Black Panther came through
the portal welding what the Infinity
Gauntlet challenging God and for joining
him and and the savage Submariner Namor
court doom off-guard turn them into
glass and Namor shattered him with his
Trident and then do be done thinkable
reformed himself from those shattered
pieces and proceeded to beat the breaks
off of one of the most intelligent
crafty battle savvy heroes that we have
he be the Black Panther which in an inch
of his life
after killing Thanos he did this at a
black panther so you say don't can't be
that powerful oh I know what the Phoenix
force well lo and behold the Phoenix
force was in Cyclops and Cyclops said
I'm gonna unleash the whole power and he
shot down with the power of the Phoenix
force and doing grabbed him by his neck
and snapped
now it's a good read I would like for
you to go pick up Secret Wars to the
second one and also pick up battleworld
and all those stories so you can read
more about marvel's ultimate big bad he
rivals eternity which is like the most
powerful character in the Marvel
Universe now get into this statue I
waited I waited two years and when the
shipment when it was told that it was
being shipped to me from Zion art Zion
art has brought to me the Hulk man
statue and I have four more statues on
pre-order with them Zion art artwork is
impeccable
Zion art is a custom art fan art studio
which will bring you top-quality
statues these statues rival the statues
with dimension size weight and scale
from sideshow from XM from prime one
Zion art is my custom go-to guys never
had a problem if anything is wrong the
same way you've reached out to them is
the same way they can respectively fix
it instantly automatically no problems
at all highly recommended you can follow
me on Instagram so you can learn more
about the statues that are in production
and stuff that are coming and you can
get into this wonderful world of custom
statues beautiful stuff here the way it
came box impeccably box not that cheesy
little styrofoam
it's a black plastic mold that is molded
to your statue and it's layered and you
remove each layer each layer has
different compartments you're gonna be
singing them pop up on the screen and
after you take them out of the
compartments the pieces of the statute
they are individually plastic wrapped
meticulously with care now I know you're
gonna say a king
do they have an art box because usually
you get a shipper box and then you get
an art box then you get the statue no
unfortunately not but what they do have
is the custom card all right now this is
Dodd Emperor doom and on the other side
is the regular doom you have two
different colors that it comes in you
have the white God Emperor doom and you
have the green regular Victor Von Doom
and I debated on getting the regular
green but what I'm going to set my eyes
on and getting is this statue here from
sideshow
it's another Holy Grail piece which I
believe this is a Holy Grail piece
it's another Holy Grail piece and I'll
be getting that doom on throne to have
them sit on throne together have a whole
section that I'll be dedicating to
Victor Von Doom because he is exactly
how I feel my villains are supposed to
be
I want a roofless I want them driven and
I want them relentless when it comes to
achieving their goals I don't like them
petty weak and it's significant I like
leaders strong powerful characters and
doom is the strongest
when it comes to power in the Marvel
Universe when it comes to villains there
is now this is the part of the video
when I tell you the light follows and
subscribe
I am so happy I don't know if it's
coming across because I'm almost in
tears that I have this here I want you
to go to Lords of gaming dotnet or you
can get all the new information on the
trade shows that the iron Lords go to
that if it ranges from packs if it
ranges from play New York III other
conferences I'm gearing up to make sure
that I go to Comic Con so I can bring
you all the information on these fine
statues also listen to the last word
with loyal Cognito and Eve on ttis but
they talk all that looters shooter means
destiny is on right now
you got Borderlands coming out you have
division 2 and you have a whole bunch of
other games like apex legends and
fortnight that's being played reviews is
up with Lord attic and I'm telling you
he's on it right now and you have snout
on the stream team who's actually
streaming video games as we speak the
iron Lords is a movement as a family
everybody stay together keep collecting
sit back watch this video as I give you
all the dimensions of this statue and I
give you some custom pictures that you
can see but don't forget to go to the
Lords of gaming dotnet so you can get
the rail or God Emperor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]